reese witherspoon is the world's richest
actress with an estimated net worth of
400 million dollars what like it's hard
the academy award-winning actress
producer and entrepreneur was born in
louisiana and raised in tennessee
as a kid reece loved watching 90210
but she wasn't dreaming about becoming
an actress she wanted to be america's
first female president eventually she
did end up president but it wasn't
exactly of the united states reece got
into acting as a young teen playing the
role of dany in the 1991 film the man in
the moon
but audiences really got to see the
depth of her acting range when she was
cast in cruel intentions
from there reese went on to star in
movies and would take on the occasional
tv cameo
hi
is rachel here i'm her sister then
legally blonde happened and reece
witherspoon was suddenly a very big deal
every major studio was calling
and the oscar goes to
[Music]
reese witherspoon
walk the line
[Music]
she was in one very dramatic love
triangle after another and was growing
increasingly tired of the roles being
offered to her
she went from our celebrity 100 list to
our overpaid actors list
she channeled her frustration with the
lack of women-led stories in hollywood
into creating her own company pacific
standard would go on to produce wild and
gone girl with reese at the helm there
were no cheesy love triangles
in 2016 her production efforts morphed
into hello sunshine which produced big
little lies the morning show and little
fires everywhere
witherspoon's media empire soon
encompassed reese's book club with the
majority of books becoming best sellers
[Music]
the club serves as a sort of pipeline
for future projects meaning books
already have a built-in audience even
before they're adapted for the screen it
was recently announced that a blackstone
backed media company is purchasing a
majority stake in hello sunshine
the deal values hello sunshine at 900
million dollars
reese will collect an estimated 120
million dollars and will still retain
about an 18 ownership state as for the
rest of reese's fortune it's post-tax
earnings from her 30-year long career as
a successful actress and producer
if you've seen her tick tock recently
you know she's keeping busy on and off
set
and who knows maybe we'll see her on
another list
[Music]
foreign